hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you
look at their faces dude but let's yeah
that's what i wanted to do
okay uh february 1 suicide of castro's
oldest son fidelito spurred the most
recent reports on several sites claiming
that fidolito left a suicide note
referring to justin trudeau as his half
brother the theory was that castro was
trudeau's father
was also shared wildly on social media
okay just for funsies and this is just
funsies
let's go let's google look at the two of
them together no there's some that are
like there's some there's like multiple
right down there right down there see
that six pictures right there there it
is yeah that's it
that's wild
that's wild
that is [ __ ] wild
when you look at those look at all of
them the top oh my god look at the top
one bro that is
wild but then you compare him to who
they say is his father
and he doesn't look anything like this
but that is wild
hey bro you need a 23 and me
right away sir
we need a you know it's wild how close
he looks if it's not his dad boy if i
was the father i'd be [ __ ] suspicious
of [ __ ] well you have you ever where's
his real dad
i think that's what this is oh
okay
well let me say hold on
okay but it's real daddy looks like his
real dad too
yeah he looks a lot like his real dad
dude a lot
okay i give up
it's just coincidence
it looks a lot like his real dad have
you ever looked hold on go back to that
go back to that don't don't take that
away go to the top the top one that
looks a lot like a man he looks a lot
like this really
a lot a lot
both men no no no no look at the nose
this shade that's not ridiculous at all
he looks a lot like a man
a lot
it's just it's just fun it's fun hey man
we're just having fun because looking at
it right there he looks a lot like his
dad